what's up guys i'm kim Bhd here and
turns out it's phone season or there's
just a lot of phones coming out right
now welcome to your first look at
another phone that may be a bit under
your radar may because of how many
phones they've come out with lately but
this one should be so this is the Oppo
find x2 Pro so I've had this phone for
about a week now and I've been very
impressed with it and it's also you
might have remembered the last video was
the s20 ultra review this phone has two
big advantages that is focusing on that
are one upping that Galaxy S 20 ultra
also this video is sponsored by Oppo so
this is a highlight video not a review
but there's some cool stuff to show so
let's just dive right into it so the
design is pretty classic for a big
smartphone a big modern phone in 2020
stop me if you've seen this before big
shiny glass and ceramic sandwich huge
display with thin bezels the main
speaker and USB type-c at the bottom
no headphone jack and then there's the
sham furred edges the antenna bands
around the outside the hole punch
display up top two in the corner
you know it's looking pretty familiar
but it does have this like micro texture
in the glass it's it's barely etched in
there and you can feel it it doesn't
make it less slippery but you can feel
the difference versus just smooth glass
and you can kind of see it if you hold
the phone at the right angle and it hits
the light looks like ridges of a
fingerprint I don't know I kind of like
it in terms of specs inside snapdragon
865 check 12 gigs of ram and half a
terabyte of ufs 3.0 storage check check
the battery is 4260 milliamp hours so a
solid size but not the biggest and you
have the optical fingerprint reader
underneath the display glass that seems
to work about as well as any other I've
seen from oneplus for example and then I
was gonna be perfectly honest I've never
really been a huge fan of opposed
software but this newest version of
color OS 7.1 it's been one of the most
interesting and impressive new parts of
the phone in it it's cleaned up a lot
and they're they're proud of how much
cleaner it is it's more customizable to
be set up the way you like and they've
included a couple more things like stock
Google Apps and the stock Google
keyboard is the default
and some of the the Oppo stuff still
appears alongside the Google version in
the app drawer but you can disable one
or the other or just stick with the
Google version which is what I'm gonna
do
there's also a multi-user mode which is
something I've wanted in more phones and
especially tablets over the years that
is smart and there's a dark mode as well
and there's also this little side bar
over here that you can keep a bunch of
shortcuts in kind of like what we've
seen on Samsung phones by default the
screen recording is in here for a 1080p
screen recording and then I've just set
up my tasks app and my weather app for
quick access or you might put your
messenger or tick-tock I don't know I'm
not here to judge whatever you want you
can put it in that sidebar over there
that's up to you and then you can also
pin apps in the RAM so you just hit the
lock button up here in the multitasker
so again I've locked the tasks app in my
RAM and it'll never leave and I open it
constantly and it doesn't have to reload
and this might be useful for some people
with bigger apps or games that you play
like all the time that you don't want to
stop running you just want them to keep
them loaded in the RAM that's the
advantage of having 12 gigs of ram so
that's a lot of good stuff already but
the two main focuses with this phone are
the display and the cameras I'm gonna
start with the screen so this is a six
point seven inch 1440p quad HD 120 Hertz
AMOLED display and yes it's all of those
things at the same time see you can see
it right here in the settings if you
were like me you were wondering why the
s20 ultra didn't have that was it a
Snapdragon a 65 limitation no this one
has a Snapdragon a 65 and it enables
that and it's beautiful you have your
independent selections for the refresh
rate and resolution now to be fair 120
Hertz at 1080p as we've seen looks
pretty much fine and you can turn on
actually auto select resolutions so
it'll toggle up or down for you based on
saving battery and that's something you
might want to do maybe if it was a 5000
or 6000 million hour battery I'd leave
it on full resolution high-speed all the
time but 4260 isn't exactly maxing it
out so you might want to turn this off
from time to time but let me know if
you'd be interested in a full review of
this phone I think if I'm Dale eing this
thing that's like the number one concern
is how long does the battery
if you just max it out now there's also
the color calibration and a bunch of
different modes that let you customize
things like color temperature on a
slider or you can turn on natural tone
or nature tone display which is
basically true tone it changes the color
temperature based on the ambient light
around you the only thing I didn't
really like is it still has the curved
edges as you can see and they are quite
curved like Samsung's done in the past
to the point where you can see some of
the content like bleeding over the sides
very dramatically that tends to give you
more accidental presses as we know but
this phone still wants to keep that near
bezel islook so yeah the display is a
big point on this phone the other is the
cameras so this is the ultra vision
camera system on the back and that is a
big camera bump so around the back here
you're looking at a forty eight
megapixel main camera a forty eight
megapixel ultra wide and a 13 megapixel
5x periscope telephoto camera and this
camera bump as you can see it's gigantic
yes the rest of the phone is pretty trim
actually but the double bump on the back
being all the way over to one side means
it'll for sure rock on a table without a
case but they're hoping that what they
can get out of these cameras will
justify it and any literature on this
phone or their presentations will pretty
much all suggest yeah the camera is the
most important feature of this phone so
I have a limited experience with it so
far but I've shot with it for a bit and
I can show you what I found basically
I've been really happy with two things
sharpness and color and you don't hear
me say color very often when talking
about smart phone cameras but this
camera for whatever reason just nails
white balance often and then tones and
hues and skin tones and in general color
is very accurate which is great dynamic
range isn't as good even when I turn HDR
on you know in more extreme dynamic
range situations you're more likely to
lose sky or lose your shadows and
exposure isn't as consistent as I've
wanted it's also a big primary sensor
again so it'll suffer from some of the
same big sensor big aperture problems we
saw on the s20 ultra but on any other
further away subjects the natural blur
is solid it's generally a high quality
fast camera yeah I was I was also really
impressed with how well the night mode
worked as well I took some low-light
photos and they speak here for
themselves night modes have gotten
really good in smartphones in the past
two years and then it will let you go up
to 60 X zoom with the periscope zoom
here so now you know the number I don't
recommend zooming in all the way but
there you have it's just a slightly
short of the hundred X and one other
spec that it falls slightly short of the
s20 Ultra is 8k video it doesn't do 8k
video but what it will do is max out at
4k 60 from any of the cameras and just
looking at the video I'm again super
happy with the colors I mean somebody
get the image processing team a topo and
give them a pat on the back for this one
because that is some really solid
accurate color and a lot of places where
many smartphone cameras have had trouble
for me so that's basically it a phone
you might not expect to hear much about
is actually making waves and some of the
things people care most about which are
camera and screen and for me also
software plus there's a bunch of other
little things the ceramic material is
nice the 65 watt super VOC fast charging
it's at the expense of not having
wireless charging but we've seen this
before smartphone makers like oneplus
like doubling down on the super fast
charging that they really believe in and
the haptic engine on this phone is also
excellent it's hard to show through
video but the spec on paper is it has
the largest x-axis motor in any Android
phone and I can tell so there you go a
lot of really solid first impressions on
the find x2 Pro and it sort of brought
me to this maybe it's a realization or
maybe we've kind of known this already
but that overkill specs are like the new
norm and a lot of these high-end
smartphones now and it's just what we
can come to expect but let me know if
you'd be interested in a full review of
this darkhorse phone also the merch is
finally back so if you want to go to
shop mkbhd calm all of it is currently
available and that's pretty much it
thanks for watching catch you guys very
soon in the next one March is gonna
start to run as well February had a lot
March it's still all happening see you
guys later peace